Intro. Hey there, fellow farmers and
agriculture
enthusiasts. Have you ever wondered how
to make every drop of water count on
your farm? Well, you're in the right
place because today we're diving into
the world of irrigation systems. I'm
your name and in this video, we'll
explore how to choose the perfect
irrigation system for your farm. Whether
you're a seasoned farmer or just
starting out, this information is
crucial for maximizing your crop yield
and conserving water. So, let's get
started and turn those fields into
thriving, well-watered
paradises. Main content. First up, let's
talk about the different types of
irrigation systems. There are three main
types we'll focus on. Drip irrigation,
sprinkler irrigation, and flood
irrigation. Drip irrigation is like
giving your plants a personal water
bottle. It delivers water directly to
the plant's roots through a network of
pipes and emitters. This system is
incredibly efficient and great for
conserving water. Sprinkler irrigation,
on the other hand, is like creating
artificial rain for your crops. It uses
a network of pipes and sprinkler heads
to distribute water over the field. This
method is versatile and can cover large
areas quickly. Flood irrigation is the
oldest method and works by flooding the
field with water. It's simple, but can
be less efficient than other methods.
Now, let's consider the factors that
influence your choice of irrigation
system. Climate plays a huge role in
determining which system will work best
for your farm. For example, in hot, dry
climates, drip irrigation might be more
effective at reducing water loss through
evaporation. The type of crop you're
growing is another crucial factor. Some
crops like rice thrive with flood
irrigation, while others like vegetables
do better with drip irrigation.
Soil type is also important to consider.
Sandy soils drain quickly, so they might
benefit from drip irrigation, while clay
soils retain water longer and could work
well with sprinkler systems. Water
availability is a key
consideration. If you have limited water
resources, you'll want to choose a more
efficient system like drip
irrigation. Let's dive deeper into the
pros and cons of each system. Starting
with drip irrigation. Pros include high
water efficiency, reduced weed growth,
and the ability to deliver fertilizer
directly to plants. Cons are the high
initial cost, potential for clogging,
and the need for regular maintenance for
sprinkler irrigation. Pros are its
versatility, ability to cover large
areas, and ease of installation. Cons
include water loss through evaporation,
potential for uneven water distribution,
and higher energy costs. Flood
irrigation. Pros are its simplicity, low
initial cost, and effectiveness for
certain crops. Cons include high water
usage, potential for soil erosion, and
uneven water
distribution. Now, let's talk about
water conservation
techniques. One effective method is
using soil moisture sensors to determine
when irrigation is needed. This prevents
overwatering and ensures your crops get
just the right amount of water. Another
technique is implementing deficit
irrigation, where you intentionally
apply less water than the crop's full
water requirements during drought
tolerant growth stages. Mulching is also
an excellent way to conserve water by
reducing evaporation from the soil
surface. Let's move on to cost analysis
and return on investment ROI. While drip
irrigation has a higher initial cost, it
can lead to significant water savings
and increased crop yields over time.
Sprinkler systems have a moderate
initial cost and can be cost effective
for larger areas. Flood irrigation has
the lowest initial cost, but may lead to
higher water bills and potentially lower
yields. To calculate ROI, consider
factors like initial investment, water
savings, crop yield increases, and labor
costs. For example, a drip irrigation
system might cost $1,000 per acre to
install, but could save you $200 per
acre annually in water costs and
increase crop yields by
15%. It's important to note that the
best irrigation system for your farm
depends on your specific
circumstances. Consider consulting with
a local agricultural extension agent or
irrigation specialist to help you make
the best decision. Remember, the goal is
to find a balance between water
efficiency, crop productivity, and cost
effectiveness. Outro. And there you have
it, folks. A comprehensive guide to
choosing the right irrigation system for
your farm. Remember, the key is to
consider all factors: climate, crop
type, soil, water availability, and your
budget. Which irrigation system do you
think would work best for your farm? Let
us know in the comments below. If you
found this video helpful, please give it
a thumbs up and share it with your
fellow
farmers. Don't forget to subscribe for
more farming tips and tricks. Until next
time, happy farming and may your crops
be ever bountiful.